jack oui de quoi parlons nous on va
parler d'une dune où tu as dans
l'histoire politique que vous avez nous
raconter la ctu nous tarde des tours
d'une hauteur des dans l'appareil
alloucherie que c'est que ça l'outarde
est un bourgeois joue mais un gros gros
joyau plus gros cône à donges à pèse 15
kilos et l'outarde dont nous allons
parler c'est l'outarde à plumes rouges
qui habite dans le désert du kalahari
qu'est le désert le plus chaud et le
plus sec de la terre donc en rouge
oiseaux et qui a une particularité c'est
extraordinaire c'est sa danse nuptiale
avant de s'accoupler le mal ou tard pour
plaire à samaa la bouscarle dans une
danse assez étonnant d'abord il
s'accroupit où il joue il reste où tu
sais plus qui sont rouges chibli qui
rendent sa tête qui vient de voix plus
qu'une énorme boule de plumes rouges
ensuite parce qu'il ya un sac là qui
sert d'emblème qu'il ya dans une
amplification de son île musique mais
musicalement je pourrais pas le poid pas
limiter la casse et à tous les micros il
me le jt le mans avant que tout le monde
a peur dans le maire pascal imiter
rugissement du lion et aux hommes sans
ronchonner km en musique - tous les mois
des ligands et candice est bien mis en
boule et qu'il a bien rue j ai cabriole
comme à chaque mois et ça pendant deux
jours de suite tout ça pour plaire à la
moutarde on sait bien qu'un oiseau comme
ça sa tante les directeurs de zoos et il
ya le directeur de zew en allemagne qui
a dit moi je veux un couple de ceuta la
plus moche pour qu'on voit le mal se
mettre en boule au jir et se mettent à
cabriolet comme un chamois parce que
vraiment c'est attirant les gens chez
moi au dimanche ou désert du kalahari
que c'est très loin ça coûtera cher pas
d'importance les zoos allemands sont
rouges sont riches on va on achète et on
se procure un monsieur ou tardent à
plumes rouges une madame ou tard leurs
plumes rouges qui font leur entrée dans
le zorro d'allemagne comme il habite le
désert du kalahari où il fait très chaud
faut pas qu'ils aient froid on les met
dans une cage bien chaud fille tiens
elle même donne dans un grand hall comme
un hall de gare comme ça ils ne sont
actuellement pas l'extérieur on chauffe
le tout très bien on met du sable
partenaires bancaires semble désert
quelques épines ou pour faire couleur
locale
on met les graines qu'il faut par terre
pour que le mal ou tardent à plumes
rouges et des sommets puisque vient
picorer leurs graines et puis on attend
on attend que le mal ou tardent à plumes
rouges dans ce délire qu'il parte énorme
boule de plumes rule qui me jugent comme
un lieu et il met à gabriele comme un
chamois à tous trois mois à temps chez
moi maintenant un nom dans ses plans
c'est peut-être malade tu es bien un
vétérinaire qui examine le mal ou cada
plus mougenot très très bien peut-être
que ses petites copines je ne sais pas
on fait revenir deux autres femelles
d'outardes à plumes rouges pour espérer
qu'il restera au moins pour elle rien du
tout il doit c'est pas on désespère on
finit par les oublier me phung l'élève
dans leur calme ils dansent pas grand
chose par la toux qui là dessus c'était
le début l'année dernière on décide de
faire des travaux donc ce zoo et
notamment d'installer des douches pour
le personnel oui et on installe la salle
de douche derrière la cage des joutes à
2 à plumes rouge ou le mal continuer à
ne pas danser à ne pas faire çà grosse
boule de plumes rouges à ne pas rougir
comme lionel pas cabriolet dans ma
savoir on installe l'appareil de l'auche
là derrière et on juillet de la lra niel
jour qui faisait très chaud le gardien
que très chaud mais pas beaucoup de
monde donc ces espèces de grandes
sociétés dans la cale les outardes il
décide de prendre une douche
tu vas dans l'appareil touche si des
habits ils tirent la sonnette
dénombre huit gauche qui tombe sur lui
et ce moment là bordeaux s'il était sous
la douche le gros temps de se rafraîchir
il entend des cris là-bas dans le hall
qui était devant la cage des joues
tarnais emmené voir qu'est ce qui lui
arrive il est devenu fou le gardien du
jour où se rhabille à toute allure mais
sa casquette ça facebook harry petit
soir et qu'est ce qui moi non la ph des
joutes arles à plumes rouges le mal
québec et ce qu'ils devaient faire une
énorme boule de plumes rouges eh oui
c'est comme rayons étaient brionnais
comme un chat droit ce qui ne l'est pas
voulu faire pendant un an il s'était
brusquement décidé à le faire au moment
où le gardien 2-0 prenait sa douche
alors pourquoi on a beaucoup réfléchi
provenance était très très simple
au deuxième qu'à l'arrivée tellement aux
sikhs qui ne peut même pas une fois par
an or les petits joutard dos quand ils
sont sortis le run on ne peut les élever
comme tous les petits loups qu'en leur
donnant des verts de frêche
henri gnagne herbes fraîches que s'il a
plu par conséquent madame outardes ne
doit avoir les yeux que s'il pleut et
par conséquent monsieur moutarde à
plumes rouges ne peut faire la cour à sa
petite compagne pour qu'elle a des yeux
qu'elle est il ou tard d'eau qui mangent
de l'herbe fraîche que s'il pleut le
gardien du zoo avait pris une douche
saab et imiter le bruit la pluie
tropicale qui vient du cros et pour
madame campbellton et c'est à dire enfin
il pleure il avait comme on faisait ça
danse ça avait déterminé les gestes
alors pour parler sa maman ça allait
conditionner les réflexes mais chez vous
par des réflexes conditionnés sûrs et
l'erdre très savants raconte ensablement
l'histoire de l'auteur de la plus le
rouge l'appareil haddouche
12 ou 13 juillet et nous avons encore
beaucoup une histoire folle comme ça